Thanks to CuriosityStream
for supporting this episode!
Go to CuriosityStream.com/microcosmos
to start streaming
thousands of documentaries
and nonfiction TV shows.
If you know about the
species Lacrymaria olor,
then you know what you're getting
when you see it under a microscope.
There's the oval body, the long neck,
the grasping and reaching out for food.
It has a distinct shape,
a distinct way of life.
The combination of its own genetics
and its surrounding environment.
It's also distinct that even
when you look at different
Lacrymaria olor and see that, sure,
these individuals don't necessarily
look exactly alike, you can still spot
the underlying framework of the species
that makes them resemble each other.
You see the morphology and the behavior
all united under the name Lacrymaria olor.
It's like looking at a house cat.
You know they have their own colors
and patterns and preferences,
but at the same time, it makes sense
why we might consider them all
to be the same species.
Felis catus.
Then you look at the species Felix manul,
better known as Pallas's cat,
and the idea that these two are relatives
of each other also feels right.
There is a sense of same but different.
And that can make the idea of a species
seem simple enough.
There are things that are like each other,
and there are things
that are less like each other.
So the idea of a species
is to define individuals
so that we can define groups
so that we can define relationships.
Except it is never so simple
when it comes
to trying to categorize life.
Because at the end of the day,
species are only a little bit about the
organisms we're looking at.
They're really more about
us and how we see the world.
Life is complicated and evolving,
which means it will always be pushing
against the bounds of our categorization.
But that doesn't mean we can't try.
The human attempt to define
a species is an exercise in futility
that is nonetheless vital
to our understanding of biology.
It provides us with the language
to describe the world around us
so that we can make comparisons
and find patterns.
So what even is a species?
Well, it depends on who you ask.
There have been several species
concepts over the past few centuries.
One of the definitions you may be familiar
with is attributed to the zoologist
Ernst Mayr who in 1942 defines species as:
“groups of actually or potentially
interbreeding natural populations
which are reproductively
isolated from other such groups.”
This describes what is known as
the Biological Species Concept.
Two species might look the same,
but if they can't reproduce together,
then they're different.
One of the major challenges
with this definition
is obvious from our journey
through the microcosmos.
Not all organisms interbreed.
Some reproduce asexually.
So how does one draw biological borders
around species
that just make copies of themselves?
There are several other species
concepts out there,
and we won't be able to explore
all of them in this episode.
But one of the other salient definitions
that helps avoid the challenges
of the Biological Species Concept
is similar to how we started this episode:
Just look at the organisms.
Look at their morphology,
describe their shape
and color in organelles
and whatever strange features appear
and use that to define
an individual species.
It seems as simple as saying
that if it's almond shaped in body
and long and neck
then it's Lacrymaria olor.
Why make it
any more complicated than that?
But deciding on what traits define
a morphological species is so dependent on
who is observing
and describing those traits.
And it creates so many more questions
for how we use morphology
to describe species and their taxonomy.
What if the neck is a little shorter?
The body a little stouter?
Does that make a different species?
And just how much can we infer about
the relationships
between two species
based on their appearance?
If they look similar
does that mean they're close relatives,
or is that some kind of phylogenetic
optical illusion?
There's no single answer
to any of those questions.
It all just depends on the organisms
and what it is you want to understand about them.
Let's look at Lacrymaria sapropelica,
a fellow member of
the Lacrymaria genus.
Its body is stout compared
to the Lacrymaria olor,
like setting down a teapot
next to a champagne glass.
Most importantly, its neck doesn't
seem to extend much beyond its body.
Instead of the constant stretching
movement of the Lacrymaria olor’s neck,
the Lacrymaria sapropelica’s neck
neck is stubby and immobile.
In fact, it looks a little bit like this
other species called Phialina caudatum,
which belongs to the genus Phialina, a genus
that closely resembles Lacrymaria
except for the obvious issue of the neck.
So if Lacrymaria sapropelica doesn't
have an extending neck,
why is it classified as
Lacrymaria and not Phialina?
Well, mostly because no one's taken
the time to officially change it.
Naming and classifying species
doesn't just happen automatically.
A person has to come along and do it.
Putting in the effort
to study the creatures
and write up their reasons
for changing its identity.
And, you know, sometimes
that person just hasn't come along.
That's the thing about people.
We've come up with these
incredible systems for describing nature.
But at the end of the day, those systems
are still subject to our very human whims.
And just to emphasize how messy
the process
of organizing organisms
is, we should add that Phialina caudatum
actually went by another name
before Lacrymaria caudatum.
But unlike Lacrymaria sapropelica,
someone did come along
and do the work of revising its place.
We don't know what motivated them
to take on the species.
Maybe they were constantly irritated
when they read the words
“Lacrymaria caudatum.”
Maybe they just happened to be studying
the species already.
Or they just wanted to publish a paper
Or maybe it's a combination of all three.
Human motivations and desires are just
as difficult to categorize as microbes.
All this messiness and subjectivity
seems built into morphology.
But we live in the age of genetics
now where sequencing
an organism is cheap
and the data objective, right?
Yes and no.
There are ways that molecular phylogeny
the use and comparison
of genetic sequences
to understand evolutionary relationships
has allowed us to see past the surface
similarities between organisms.
Amoebas, for example,
were thought to be closely
related because of their use of
pseudopodia or false feet,
but their genetic underpinnings revealed
that amoebas are actually
the culmination of many different species
and groups and phyla.
They just happened to resemble each other
in this one major way.
And those results, the specificity
they've allowed us in redefining these
species, have given us new understanding
about their evolution and behaviors.
But data, as concrete and undeniable as it
feels, is still
in the eye of the beholder.
Like, let's say we found
a new species with a short,
not extending neck
and say we decided to name it.
Lacrymaria microcosmosii.
we're excited to find it,
and we're even more excited to study
it and report all the genetic information
we can find
describing the organism
in terms of its genetic code
that we registered to a depository
for other scientists to look at.
But then let's say that shortly
after our discovery
other masters of microscopes
turn up their own
Lacrymaria microcosmosii discoveries.
The morphologies
match what we've described.
But when we compare our genetic sequences
to what they've found,
there are differences.
The question is how big do
those differences have to be
to make the organism itself different?
Do they define a new species,
an entirely new genus?
At what point do we decide
something is too different
to be the same or even just similar?
That's not necessarily a
problem that DNA in computers
will be able to solve for us.
There's still going to be a person who has
to decide, a person who has to make
a subjective call based on the data
presented and the questions asked.
And their definition
will probably have exceptions
to leaving blanks, in our understanding.
But blanks are exciting.
They leave us room for new ways
of seeing things, of asking things,
because our definitions are an attempt
to bring the expansiveness of biology
into something we can understand,
something we can speak and read.
But life expands beyond
those constraints in ways
we know, in ways we have yet to find out.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us.
As we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us.
This episode has been brought to you
by CuriosityStream.
a subscription streaming service
that offers thousands of documentaries
and nonfiction TV shows
from some of the world's best filmmakers,
including award
winning exclusives and originals.
They cover topics like history, nature,
science, food technology, travel and more.
And since we're already on the topic
of long necked creatures,
why not check out the documentary
The Woman Who Loves Giraffes?
It's the story of Anne Dagg, a zoologist
who in 1956 took a solo journey
to South Africa to study giraffes
in the wild and helped pioneer
the field of giraffe biology.
And you can find it right now
on CuriosityStream.
You can stream CuriosityStream’s Library,
including their collections
of curated programs
hand-picked by their experts
to any device
for viewing any time anywhere.
And if you go to curiositystream.com/microcosmos
and use the code “Microcosmos” to sign up.
It will only cost
you $14.99 for an entire year.
The names you're seeing on the screen
right now, they are people
who are supporting us on Patreon.
Patreon is a place where you can go
and give a little bit of money
to the things that you really think
should exist in the world.
And all of those people really think that
Journey to the Microcosmos should exist.
And we agree with them.
And we're so thankful to them.
If you want to see more from our master
microscopes, James Wieiss,
you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us,
there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby.